it is day 26 of russia's war of
aggression against ukraine i'm michael
loku welcome
at least eight people are dead after a
neighborhood on the outskirts of kiev
came under heavy shelling overnight and
despite the weeks-long siege the eastern
port of mariopol has defied a russian
deadline to surrender the european
union's top diplomat says russia's
tactics are a war crime
a blast that shook the entire city of
kiev
fires erupted amid the wreckage of the
mall that was hit by russian shelling
firefighters that rushed to the scene
were able to pull at least one person
out of the rubble alive
but the aftermath is a scene of
devastation
parts of the mall were completely
obliterated
windows blown out
metal twisted
craters in what used to be
the parking lot
civilians killed in the bombing of
civilian infrastructure
russian troops have been hitting kiev
with a series of strikes including on
apartment buildings
but for now their advance has largely
stalled on the outskirts of the city
ukraine rejected an ultimatum for the
city of mariupol in the country's east
to surrender to russian forces
russia had offered safe passage out of
mariupol but only for those who would
lay down their weapons
conditions in the besieged city continue
to be difficult
food and water are scarce
medical help is hard to come by
ukraine's president volody mirzalenski
again condemned the attack on the city
the blockade of marijupo will go down in
history as a war crime
to do this to a peaceful city is
terrorism that will be remembered in
centuries to come
and the more ukrainians tell the world
about it the more support we will get
the more russia uses terror against
ukraine the more it will suffer the
consequences
plan to keep on resisting
surrender they say is out of the
question
sergey patooka former deputy minister of
justice and now a law lecturer at the
national university of kiev joins us now
um sergey thank you so much for making
the time for us today but first
we've seen this morning the terrible
destruction caused by russian bombs to a
kiev neighborhood how are people in the
city coping with this violence and and
how are you coping
right uh so this is the shopping mall in
my area
and i could actually both hear and see
the blast last night
so um we are talking to each other to
our neighbors on on various chats and
people are just of course uh straight
away rushing to get more information
what was hit what are the consequences
what's going on uh there's no panic in
the city uh people are just making sure
that you know their close ones are safe
and if they left the houses if the
houses are intact and if the windows are
still there so i think we are at this
point quite used to these attacks and uh
the you know everybody is well
coordinated and knows what can happen
sergey i have to say i'm going to keep
this personal for a moment i think so
many viewers watch what's going on in
ukraine and they uh they look at it with
some degree of incredulity in fact
looking at you right now you as as cool
as ice how are you coping with this what
is going on with the people that allows
them to just soldier on
you can't believe how humans are
adapting to any circumstances they're
living in i mean it's it's a shock the
first days but then people get used to
sirens
people get used to uh attacks again i'm
in this neighborhood that that here's uh
the you know the shots throughout all
those three weeks so we're kind of used
to that you go to you know to do
shopping and you hear some blasts that's
that's just part of your life now you're
taking precautions but you're keeping
cool those who could not cope with that
left the city and had a right to do that
that that those who stayed we know
what's gonna happen we know that we have
to be prepared we're psychologically
stable and we're just flexible enough to
get used to that
psychologically stable okay more
questions for you keith's mayor vitaly
klitschko has just announced a
reinforced curfew in the capitol
starting later tonight
asking people to stay either at home or
in shelters why is he doing that
right michael so that's the third time
that this has been happening and each
time i think it was for for a reason
that we were expecting uh russian
attacks on the ground within the city we
expected incursion of their uh small
groups within the city and in order to
be able to effectively stop them you
have to ensure that no civilian is
outside so i think everybody understands
that and that means that tomorrow
whoever is met on the street can be
presumed to be an enemy and therefore
you know the people can you know our
armed forces can react upon it because
we've seen the you know the russians
disguised as civilians as ambulances as
firefighters so it's critical to have uh
this curfew for our armed forces and
territorial defense to be able to stop
anyone anyone who is on the street
without sound reason understood i want
to get to mariopol uh the residents
there
of course as you know have refused a
russian ultimatum to surrender so it
seems that determination to resist the
russian invasion remains strong despite
the fact that thousands are trapped
exactly we've we i mean i'm i'm talking
to many people i talk to my neighbors to
my friends i see what's going on the
morale stays high i don't think anyone
is panicking at this point
on the country people get more
coordinated and better organized we are
hoping for the best but prepared for the
worst
that is aseki battukov a former deputy
justice minister of ukraine
really appreciate your time and
perspective sir
you